artificial intelligences everywhere
every company is taking advantage of it
or needs to take advantage of it
we at Stanford are thinking about that
across the university both the business
point of view but also actually this
societal point of view to a lot of
people ai is just magic through this
program they can have a little bit of a
better understanding of what's actually
entail honestly it was fear that drove
me here you know I mean everywhere you
just keeping here you know you keep
hearing about AI and what are you doing
I'm a non-technical person I want to
make sure that I'm in the forefront of
it later per se is very valuable however
if you don't apply it and don't put it
in the right algorithms
you'll also not get much value out of it
each day starts with an overview
provided by a world-class faculty member
who's an expert in their field
no equations nothing complicated going
on just high-level insights and then
later on we take a either a deeper dive
or we have someone from industry talk
about some of the issues in translating
some of the ongoing research and
artificial intelligence into business
impact we will better understand what's
the legal regulatory ethical framework
around the AI topics on the other hand
what can we do in order to improve
customer experience or create additional
revenues so combining those two
perspectives I think it's a great value
of the program what's really great about
this program is we're drawing from all
of campus we have some great people
coming in from the engineering school of
the business school and we've also
brought in someone from the medical
school to bring that perspective as well
as the law school
if you're gonna learn about AI you want
to do it here in Silicon Valley this is
where everything is happening we're
within a few miles of many of the
companies that are implementing AI as
are their core business strategy whether
I'm an engineer whether I'm you know in
finance whether I'm an you know public
sector doesn't matter things are
changing fast of what do we need to do
there's just really no place like
Stanford in terms of bringing all of
this expertise together in one place I
saw this program and it's like it's
brilliant way to get introduced and
there's a personal touch and this is one
week of intensive learning so I mean
this environment you you can't beat